[Musique]
en avril dernier l'association petits
coeurs a lancé une opération de
solidarité afin d'offrir un logement
décent à daniela une mère de famille
atteinte d'un cancer qui vivait jusqu'à
présent dans des conditions insalubres
aujourd'hui c'est l'inauguration d'une
maison d'une maison de bouloc
nous la paix avec l'ensemble des
réunionnais daniela tenir à ces deux
mamans autour des buts a fait appel à
moi
elle vivait elle et des malades déjà
sont arrondis commence-t-on m'arrête et
heavy punk trash vraiment très très très
insalubre l'électricité des branques de
partout la plus haute et on perd en
direct à son cas la salle des pins
elle avait point la cuisine était à
l'extérieur les joueurs la prospective
efficace et seront
salut mais pas les normes est un grand
moment ce vendredi 27 octobre à tan
rouge daniela découvre enfin sa nouvelle
maison
tout s'est passé à parapente pas comme
ça beaucoup de choses à changer
elle l'a réalisé l'association ti coeur
a fait appel à de nombreux bénévoles
pour que ce projet se concrétise
touché par l'histoire de daniela c'est
tout naturellement que le département a
souhaité financer une partie des travaux
donc quand on a lu
ça peut pas faire autrement que de
parce qu'il était vraiment dans
savoie complet que monsieur o relié à
son tour
le contact avec le département et tout
de suite on a répondu présent
les bénévoles étaient présents ainsi que
les proches et la famille de daniela
pour l'accueillir comme il se doit dans
sa nouvelle maison
[Musique]